yeah hello welcome to this video it's a
bit of a late start against the tech GM
Julian auction he escaped a completely
lost position last time out of the same
opening and we'll see how he does this
time I mean he escaped I killed myself
whatever everything at the same time but
um the whole the whole game felt a bit
wrong for white so let's see what he's
doing next I actually totally dislike
ones position here already but it's a
it's a line I mean so um let's see he
took only six hmm check this and then
you five I had to analyze that but I
wondered I just wonder how I'm not
losing a pawn here f takes is wrong it
blunders the night yeah there's a very
good question that's a very good
question this looks wrong here for me I
can check here which leads to complete
chaos pop probably have to
I queen DeGeorge simply Queen d2 sugar
ah what did I want to screw up what did
I do wrong there isn't d5 correct wow
wow wow wow and cop how weird how weird
i confuse my openings probably yes'm now
he wins before wow we have to Castle
first or something that's really strange
doesn't happen to me all that often such
a disastrous opening position Wow
yeah i'm somewhat somewhat alive at
least I mean it's not good but this is
more per gems I'm still alive than alive
and kicking from simple minds I'm not
kicking now I make actually with Nazi
for why these are usually better of
course so say anyway to trade this off
g5 is going to go h4 yeah this I wanted
actually I thought this is Miss placing
the night
so am I going back here
oops no g5 maybe back to the 300 yeah
yeah even though I somehow felt this
wasn't great what he did I think he
probably did a good job I to d3 keeps
everything nicely covered
92 f six if I take everything I go no
the knee s 9 f 6 immediately
yeah it's probably a bad ending anyway I
was thinking Knight f6 trade everything
light xe5 but yes yeah he's got some
Nigeria one of the things that when I
think probably more
yeah as I said this is probably winning
for why but I don't really see an
alternative cap this ending should win
for him with my terrible night down he
is coming up here yeah awful this is
this was mostly an opening disaster
really I'd really wonder what I did
there I've played this this more than
once and I think usually very quiet and
cried well I probably have to Castle for
a stem in this position
after castle first I guess so
now you can just take the a seven-point
King b7 and sky morning yeah it didn't
really matter it's just completely lost
okay I am somehow like I don't think so
I keeping imprisoned down yeah I was a
slight checks now like King b7 King t6
what's going on here I don't get it I'm
just too bad in the ending i think i
know i don't get the moose
I don't know this game is still going on
g3 he can just stop it
check check check check is for instance
because he has more time but that was
the worst day ever i'm sorry i mean yeah
if we could could have just one like
with every move i mean and then and he
screwed up someone really strange cap
stalemate okay that was that was really
a bad game ever both players probably
wow ok so ive played this a couple of
times and I okay okay okay now we're
getting somewhere like before is of
course just the blunder because I can
take it right no I cannot take it like
they take okay so so if won't be five I
have analyzed this why is that looking I
really don't get a t5 I've the chicken
got the g g3 Wow but this is stuff you
should should should know and not trying
to find g3 Kashuk
talk about crazy so what's going on here
if he moves the king since this is
probably good 93-94 yes that looks kind
of okay I don't don't trust the line
though here if I have to take with the
beep on then this is kind of strange
because you know these pieces they won't
be good him I know the computer likes my
position but I'm kind of skeptical here
but this is the explanation for my bed
opening position I have to play the I'm
talking to show I analyze this for my
bank or serious but I just I just did
not i just did not remember queen age
for him check Jeremy Jamm just a pawn
down cat and I think he did a really
good technical job of it first I mean
this is completely willing ending
provide and all that and and then we get
to software either I'm a complete idiot
or I just don't understand i mean i am
not really great at those endings i know
this but top i mean i didn't understand
anything here I mean up to here
everything's cool and now I went here
and why not just King b7 like ki lakeer
King b7 may be here this should really
win I don't know why 97's necessary can
you let us do this or why am I not
losing
I don't get it 97-93 still there I mean
everything wins again Kingda 7 and he
never did this and now it gets kind of
interesting yeah g3 I didn't go because
yeah well takes takes takes a teen gets
and I want to win this you know probably
20 / wishes with age 5 and he could have
taken can be seven again win I'll be 59
back v6 it just gets Jack gets this
first in the way in which have 10
seconds so I shall I didn't really play
anything great here check check check
yeah below check check check yeah okay
so just a click first no check he's got
make here huge stalemated me wow that
was it really a weird game a really
weird game why didn't you just get to
the beep horn down I have no idea but I
have to remember the opening you have to
remember that it's really important this
was what I mainly analyzed and then I'm
going to be five I remember this one
before and I takes doesn't work always
said to draw or something just quickly
I'm curious no one there's no nothing
here the trap is no okay that's bad for
back okay um thanks for watching